ce bateau vient de l'île de margarita
avec à son bord près de trois tonnes de
poissons destiné à un importateur local
aujourd'hui il sera contrôlé jusque en
fond de cale les autorités voulant
s'assurer qu'ils n'emmènent exactement
les quantités qu'il a déclaré et aucune
espèce protégée le marché noir est
estimée à 25% du poisson importée et
nombreux sont les complices sur le
marché local ça peut être 200 400 mille
kilos de poissons qui sont débarqués en
plus la difficulté que c'est alors il se
trouve que parfois il ya des
importateurs qui achètent en plus ce
poisson il se trouve aussi que ce sont
parfois tout un tas de trafiquants pour
peu que ce soit du poisson avarié bas ça
peut devenir compliqué pour le
consommateur donc tout ce poisson arrive
sur les marchés informels et crée une
concurrence déloyale vous comprenez bien
avec ce qui importe de façon légale et
puis avec ceux qui produisent avec les
pêcheurs aujourd'hui le capitaine du
bateau et dans les raids lalèyè les
contrôles sont devenus très dur ici à
martinair quins il te reste du poisson à
bord la mode est terrible pour un
pêcheur cl tu attrapes tu perds tour tu
perds ton travail tu ne peut plus venir
marquer un équipage a le droit de garder
du poisson pour sa consommation
personnelle
au delà la monde serait de 1500 euros
par kilo non déclarés et interdiction de
revenir sur le territoire
mais les contrôles ne s'arrête pas là la
daf vérifiez aussi la qualité sanitaire
du produit qu'ils soient bien glace
une bonne conservation donc en fait
l'objectif de ce contrôle est tout
simplement de vérifier que le poisson un
état de fraîcheur satisfaisant donc qui
peut être présenté à la consommation
humaine
si vous regardez alors moi c'est pas
vraiment l'intérêt du poisson des fruits
sarde et rockets vivaneau chaque espèce
est inspectée et aujourd'hui
exceptionnellement des poissons seront
prélevés et envoyés pour analyse dans un
laboratoire de métropole alors les
analyses on a plusieurs et à le
chlordécone
il ya la dioxine hydrocarbures mais mon
quart d'heure aromatiques polycycliques
et pcb
ça fait partie d'un plan national en
fait quand qui rique est établie contre
la martinique est généralement lors de
ces contrôles est ce que vous avez une
mauvaise surprise
non pour l'instant on n'a pas trouvé de
prélèvement justement positif
en cas de problème l'espèce sur est
interdite d'un port depuis la zone
concernée
depuis le début de l'année 50 comprend
le vétérinaire ont été menées sur les
quais ainsi que 30 opérations des
affaires maritimes